Die Ligatour ist mal wieder da. Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Fußball der Männer. Heute sind drei Ligen dran. Spanien, Italien und in einem einzelnen Segment noch England. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Schön, dass Fabian Pakulat und Christian Bernhardt hier sind. Und später hören wir noch Uli Hebel. Und genau jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schön, dass ich hier wieder bekannte Gesichter habe. Hallo Fabian.
Ich glaube, die Woche hat ihm auch wirklich sehr gut getan, weil er hat ja auch das Weiterkommen gegen Napoli danach für eine Generalabrechnung genutzt Richtung Journalier. Man merkt schon, wie viel Dampf da auf dem Kessel ist, auch dass er jetzt wieder gegen Atletico fliegt. Also Trainer bei Barca sein, glaube ich, auch noch als Xavi mit der Geschichte. Also was du da außenrum mitkriegst. Ich durfte dir das Hinspiel kommentieren, Napoli-Barca. Da gab es ja auch auf der PK vor dem Spiel. Da saß der niederländische zentrale Mittelfeldspieler. Der Jong, danke. Genau, der ja auch gemeint hat Richtung Journalier. Was ist denn los? Was schreibt er für Sachen? Über die angeblichen Gehälter, die er verdient und so. Man sieht bei Barca, der Druck ist immens. Xavi hat ja auch mal seinen Rücktritt zum Saisonende bekannt gegeben. Da hat er auch gesagt, du hast hier manchmal das Gefühl, es geht jeden Tag um Leben und Tod. Ich glaube, all dieser Druck ist dann halt auch abgefallen. Ich bin völlig bei Fabian. Als wir das weiterkommen, ja, total wichtig. Und dann auch noch gegen Atletico ein 3-0 nachlegen.
Jetzt wieder Tabell 2, jetzt ist eigentlich wieder alles 11-0.
8 Punkte Rückstand, klar, ich meine Real für trotzdem Meister. Aber zum ersten Mal seit 2019, 20, ist man wieder ins Viertelfinale gekommen. Damals gegen Bayern ausgestiegen. Das war dann dieses 2 zu 8, also quasi die Corona-Saison. Aber danach Achtelfinale gegen PSG raus, zweimal in der Gruppenphase raus, jeweils mit Bayern in der Gruppe. Und jetzt ins Viertelfinale gekommen gegen, okay, wieder PSG. Aber ja, finde ich sehr schön, dass Xavi hier auch mal positiv erwähnt wird. Dann fehlt uns noch der Ansatz hier aus der Serie A. Ja, und da kann ich an Fabian direkt anknüpfen, denn auch ich habe mir einen Trainer rausgesucht, eines großen Clubs, nämlich Piorli von Milan. Bei Milan geht es ja zuletzt auch viel abseits des Spielfelds. Da gab es ja vor Kurzem auch Untersuchungen oder es gibt es immer noch der Finanzbehörden über die Übernahme von Redbird. Das sind einige Fragezeichen. Die Frage, was da alles genau gelaufen ist, da steht auch im Raum – also das wird jetzt noch dauern, bis alles ausgewertet ist – aber es stand auch mal im Raum, ob es vielleicht Richtung nächste Saison zu Punktabzug kommen könnte. Also wirtschaftlich sehr schwer zu durchschauen, das Thema momentan. Dementsprechend hat Piolli dauernd den Namen Antonio Conte, der so über seinem Kopf schwebt, weil er eben auch – und da lernen wir wieder bei Redbird – Zlataniborimic seit kurzem offizieller Berater von Kardinale, von Präsidentnis. Vieles darauf hindeutet, dass vielleicht im Sommer die Zeit von Piolli zu Ende sein könnte, aber er schafft es, die Mannschaft sehr gut davon abzuschirmen. Sie haben jetzt fünf Pflichtspiel-Siege in Serie hintereinander, marschieren bis jetzt gemütlich durch die Europa League, sind mittlerweile auch Zweiter, sind dann Juve vorbeigezogen. Und wie gesagt, also die ganze Gemengelage. Piolli muss sich auch auf jeder Pressekonferenz fragen zu nicht sportlichen Themen verhalten. Und er macht es mit seiner gewohnten, ruhigen Art, sagt die Sachen, die man logisch sagen muss, so von wegen, ja, wir konzentrieren uns auf uns, wir als Mannschaft. Aber er kriegt es halt auch hin. Und Milan hat jetzt wirklich zuletzt wieder, ich glaube, sie haben auch seit Anfang, sie hatten die eine Niederlage, gab es im Hinspiel, in der Europa League im 16. Finale, im Rückspiel, wo sie aber das Hinspiel 3-0 gewonnen hatten, wo eigentlich alles klar war. Und dann gab es halt diese eine Niederlage in Monza. Ansonsten haben sie mehr oder weniger alles gewonnen. Sie spielen auch wieder offensiv, also gerade sehr torreich. Viele deutliche Siege, Leao trifft, Pulisic glaube ich in den letzten vier Spielen jeweils getroffen. Und deswegen wollte ich auch Piolli nehmen. Ein kurzer Blick zurück ins Sommer. Da gab es ja auch einen großen Cut bei Milan. Maldini wurde ja gegangen, sozusagen die ganze technische Führung. Tonali wurde verkauft für viel Geld. Und dann hat Piolli auch deutlich mehr Mitspracherecht bei den neuen Transfers gehabt. Und das kam in relativ viele neue. Loftus Chig, Reinders, Chukwese, Okafor, Pulisic. Und man muss jetzt sagen, also diese Zahl, ich bin gespannt, wie ihr sie einschätzt, aber ich, als ich sie gehört habe, fand sie ziemlich beeindruckend. Die Neuden, die jetzt im Sommer kamen, das sind ziemlich viele, ja, die haben mittlerweile in dieser Saison 40 Tore geschossen. Und das findet, also auch wettbewerbsübergreifend, also nicht nur in der Liga. Aber das finde ich schon beeindruckend. Also wie gesagt, gerade Julisic, seit Wochen eigentlich in herausfragender Form. Okafor trifft jetzt, war zwar lange verletzt. Choukouets hat jetzt auch mal getroffen. Loftus Chic funktioniert seit Wochen sehr, sehr gut. Also ja, Milan hatte viele neue. Aber trotzdem, als ich die Zahl sah, dachte ich mir, okay, wenn deine Neuden 40 Buden machen und du einer derjenigen im Sommer ja warst, der da definitiv mehr Mitspracherecht hatte, dann würde ich sagen, kann man das erst mal untergelungen abheften. Aber absolut. Spielen jetzt dann in Europa League Viertelfinale gegen die Roma. Genau. Da hat man zweimal gewonnen. Wie bitte? Da hat man zweimal gewonnen. Und, müssen wir nicht groß drum rum reden, ist ein Riesenziel von Milan in dieser Saison, der Europa League. Weil Champions League-mäßig stehen sie ja richtig gut da in der Liga. Also, glaube ich, haben ja 11 Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz 5. Also, da wird nicht mehr viel passieren. Und deswegen, der Fokus ist da an Milan ja auch mit seiner Tradition, wenn man sich als großer Europapokalferein sozusagen sehnt, ist da definitiv das Ziel in der Europa League sehr, sehr, sehr weit zu kommen. Sollte Milan weiterkommen und sollte Leverkusen weiterkommen, dann werden wir diese Partie sehen. Dann freuen wir uns darauf. Ihr zwei, es war genau wie immer, wenn man weniger Leute ist, dann hat man irgendwie auch mehr Zeit für Rückfragen und es wird genauso lang wie sonst. Aber ich danke euch sehr, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Vielen Dank an Fabian Pakolat. Danke dir, Fabian. Erhol dich noch gut, bitte. Nichts versteppen wäre wichtig. Herzlichen Dank an Christian Bernhardt. Danke dir, dass du hier warst. Aber mir auch. Und wir machen jetzt hier an dieser Stelle weiter. Hoffentlich zumindest mit Uli Hebel. Uli Hebel ist jetzt bei mir. Wir wollen sprechen über die Premier League. Uli, ich freue mich, dass du da bist.
Ich freue mich auch. Grüß dich.
Grüße dich. Wollen wir mit dem Positiven oder etwas negativeren Thema anfangen?
Ich weiß nicht, was ihr jetzt hattet, was du brauchen kannst, was dein Gebüt brauchen kannst.
Wir hatten schon alles. Das war eine wilde Achterbahnfahrt. Auch für die Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das Positivste war eigentlich, dass wir fast immer einen Bezug zum FC Malaga hatten. Da überlege ich jetzt gerade, ob es hier bei deinen beiden Teams einen gibt. Vielleicht am ehesten bei den Wolves, aber mir fällt keiner ein. Dafür fehlt der Malaga.
Da muss ich jetzt mal überlegen, ob da irgend einer im Kader stünde, der da mal war. Das wäre jetzt komplett gar nicht ausgeschlossen.
Aber lass mal über die Wolves sprechen. Warum sind die denn für dich ein Thema?
Also die laufen, glaube ich. Das wären auch so etwas wie die Anzang Heroes, wenn ich so will, generell, weil die eigentlich nie genannt werden. Und ich hatte, wenn ich ehrlich bin, vor der Saison durchaus Sorge um die. Die haben ja ganz, ganz kurz vor der Saison ihren Trainer verloren. Beziehungsweise, ja, lassen wir es mal so, verloren. Da gab es ein paar Unstrittigkeiten über den Kader und so was. Und dann ist der gegangen und mit ein paar Tagen Notiz hat dann Gary O'Neill übernommen, der vorher wiederum etwas überraschend bei Bournemouth hat gehen müssen, obwohl er einen richtig guten Job gemacht hat. Und da sind ein paar Charaktere in dem Kader, von denen ich mir nicht 100% sicher war, ob die wirklich all das tun würden, was es bräuchte, um drin zu bleiben. Die haben in der letzten Saison die erste Hinrunde fürchterlich gespielt und haben sich wirklich richtig hängen lassen. Dann kam Lopetegui und es hat eigenmaßen gut funktioniert, haben aber dann den letzten Teil der Aufstiegsgang verloren in Ruben Nevš, der sich fürs Geld entschieden hat und Saudi Arabien. Und ohne den waren die eigentlich immer eine ganze Klasse schlechter. Und dann kamen ein, zwei unbekannte Leute, was jetzt Leistungsvermögen betrifft oder sogar gänzlich unbekannt, was jetzt einfach so grundsätzlich den Namen betrifft, in Belgrad zum Beispiel. Und dann ging es aber schon los, dass die am ersten Spieltag Manchester United ein ziemlich gutes Spiel geliefert haben und ging eigentlich immer so weiter. Und ich glaube, wesentlicher Faktor dafür ist der Trainer Gary O'Neil, den ich unheimlich schätze, den ich für einen der taktisch allerstärksten in der ganzen Liga halte, weil der immer so ganz leichte Anpassungen zu jedem Gegner vornimmt. Das heißt, der geht mal ins hohe Pressing, wenn es dem Gegner überhaupt nicht liegt. Der lässt aber auch mal den Gegner kommen, bleibt erstmal passiv oder scheinbar passiv, um dann zuzugreifen. Der spielt mal mit einer Dreierkette, mal mit einer Viererkette. Je nachdem, auch wirklich recht fließend innerhalb des Spiels die Veränderungen. Also, ist ja sowieso glaube ich nicht allzu sinnvoll, immer nur zu sprechen von der Grundformation, weil die sind immer eh bloß beim Anschlusskreis. Aber danach läuft das wirklich sehr, sehr gut, hat einzelne Spieler wieder aufgeweckt, glaube ich auch. Sowas wie zum Beispiel Aït Nouri in bessere Rollen gesteckt. Hat natürlich auch, muss man auch ehrlicherweise dazu sagen, das Glück, dass ein, zwei gesund sind oder gesünder wie zum Beispiel Pedro Neto, der eigentlich dauerhaft ausfiel. Der ist jetzt halt mal wieder wenigstens zum Teil da gewesen und das merkt man, weil das echt ein richtig guter Mann ist. Hat aber auch einzelne Spieler eben gut entwickelt. Durchaus nochmal Schritte gehen lassen. Bell Guard gut eingefügt. Matthäus Kunja sieht gut aus. Ist eigentlich bis auf den Abschluss einer der progressivsten Spieler der ganzen Liga, was vor allen Dingen sogenannte Ball-Carries betrifft, also einfach den Ball quasi durch reinschleppen, Raumgewinn erzielen und so. Und macht aus einem Kader, das kann man jetzt im Nachhinein schon auch so sehen, naja gut, da steckt auch viel Talent drin. Das war aber für mich tatsächlich 50-50 mit der Tendenz zu, oh, ich weiß nicht. Und er hat aus dem Team gemacht, das jetzt in der Liga gut drauf ist, drei Siege aus vier Spielen, das zwar jetzt im FA Cup im Viertelfinale raus ist gegen den Zweitligisten, da haben sie sich deutlich mehr ausgerechnet, allerdings auch nicht mit der komplett ersten Garnitur. Ich kann dir jetzt gar nicht sagen, warum das so ist, weil ich das Spiel so nicht verfolgt habe. Und trotzdem in der Liga auf Platz 9, also mit best of the rest sozusagen, und haben in Gary O'Neill einen Trainer, glaube ich, den man jetzt in Zukunft auf dem Tableau haben sollte. Ich habe nur mal zum Beispiel, dass du weißt, wie hoch ich den einordne, habe nur mal nachgedacht, was würde denn passieren, wenn England in der Europameisterschaft in der Gruppe kleben bliebe. Oder meinetwegen sogar die nächste Runde wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht reichen, wenn es aufgeht, der dann ja wiederum angeblich auf dem Zettel von United stehen soll, was einfach Wahnsinn wäre, weil dann würde es komplett implodieren. Wäre richtig lustig. Würde ich auch gerne sehen. Aber einmal überlegt, wer könnte das sein? Wer wäre denn verfügbar? Eddie Howe hat man immer mal so kokettiert damit. Ich glaube, Gary O'Neil wäre perfekt. Ich glaube wirklich, das wäre genau der richtige Mann. Das wäre jemand, der am Anfang seiner Karriere steht, der hungrig ist, der das als totale Chance begreifen würde, der aber mit all diesen Spielern umgehen kann, weil er jetzt am zweiten Klub zeigt, dass er aus allen Möglichkeiten, egal wie geartet, alles machen kann. Und das jede Woche. Also es ist nicht nur zufällig mal für zwei, drei Wochen so gewesen, sondern Woche für Woche sind die top eingestellt. Und es gibt kein Spiel mehr mit Wolverhampton-Beteiligungen, wo ich denke, um Himmels willen. Sondern die sind immer gut, weil die den immer dem Gegner sozusagen einfach fast annullieren. Und das mag ich total gerne an denen. Und deswegen soll der auch mal genannt sein, ist wahrscheinlich dann auch wirklich das allerletzte Team, das wir noch nie besprochen haben. Und dann wird es also höchste Zeit.
Ja, finde ich sehr schön. Ich habe, nachdem Jürgen Klopp seinen Abschied verkündet hat, habe ich irgend so ein Nerd-Taktik-Blog gelesen, wurde mir irgendwie über soziale Netzwerke reingespielt. Und die haben quasi nur geguckt, wer würde vom Spielstil, von dem, was sein Team eben spielen lässt, am besten zu Liverpool passen. Und da waren eben drei Trainer. Und einer von denen war interessanterweise Sebastian Hoeneß, wo sie so fast ein Perfect-Fit sogar ausgemacht haben, einfach nur von dem, was Stuttgart spielt und was Liverpool spielt. Und dann eben als Outside-Candidate, der eben nicht so ganz von den Statistiken her passt, aber eben von allen anderen, war tatsächlich Gary O'Neill. Und da war ich auch so, dass ich mir dachte, okay, interessant.
Und jetzt zeige ich dir was. Der neue CEO der Family Sports Group, Michael Edwards, zurück. Der war schon mal Sportdirektor, ist jetzt nur einfach aufgestiegen sozusagen. Und der neue technische Direktor, Richard Hughes, die haben zusammen vor 20 Jahren bei Portsmouth schon zusammengesessen in den Videoanalyse-Räumen. Das ist also nicht komplett ausgeschlossen. Ich habe das bei uns im Podcast auch gesagt. Außen, Außenseiter-Chance, weil Liverpool sich 30 mal überlegen wird, ob das schon geht für ihn. Aber in der Making habe ich irgendwie so das Gefühl, das ist nicht ausgeschlossen. Das ist so, irgendwie hätte, würde das passen. Also vor Klopp, vor dieser jetzt – ich glaube, da kann man eher dazu sagen, das ist dann nicht so groß gegriffen – vor dieser Ära wäre der schon ein Kandidat gewesen. Weil das genau die Art Trainer war, die sie immer gesucht hatten. Und irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, das könnte eines Tages passieren.
Nicht schlecht. Und woran liegt es aber, dass die Wolves so oft verlieren? Also sie haben fast so viele Niederlagen wie Siege. Zwölf Siege, fünf Unentschieden, elf Niederlagen. Und da sind quasi die Punkte verloren gegangen, die eben dazu führen würden, dass man irgendwie in die Top-Six vielleicht irgendwo sich heranrobt. Zumindest sechs Punkte Rückstand sind es gerade auf United, auf dem sechsten Tabellenplatz. Woran liegt das?
Einfache Antwort an den Gegnern, weil die Liga einfach brutal stark ist. Und sie haben dann die Niederlagen ganz oft – wir haben über United gesprochen zu Beginn der Saison. Sie haben, glaube ich, gegen Liverpool jeweils verloren, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Sie müssten gegen United schnell nachschauen, ob das stimmt. Aber das habe ich damals auch gemacht. Ja, genau, auch 4-3 verloren haben, also zweites Mal. Gegen Arsenal waren sie gut, aber haben verloren. Dann gab es so 1-2-50-50-Spiele. Ich habe sie mal am Montag gemacht gegen Fulham, da haben sie auch verloren. 3-2, da waren sie allerdings besser. Also klare Gegnerqualität. In manchen Spielen auf Augenhöhe sind sie ein bisschen wild manchmal. Plus die Chancenverwertung. Also Kunja, kannst du in jedem Spiel ein Expected Goal hinschreiben. Ich würde tippen, dass so in etwa dann der Outcome bei 0, 25 oder so ist, weil dessen Chancenverwertung einfach zu wenig ist. Wang hatte mal eine Zeit, in der extrem effektiv war, aber schon gar nicht effizient. Wobei, da gab es auch mal sogar eine ganz kurze Phase, in der er wirklich aus einem Tor schiessen Tor gemacht hat, weil ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher bin, ob das nicht sogar letzte Saison war. Aber die brauchen schon noch ein bisschen viel. Ich würde die immer als Overachiever nennen. Die haben aus meiner Sicht mehr geholt, als sie hätten holen dürfen. Und deswegen stehen sie auf Platz 9, aber es gibt sie schon noch, diese wilden Nummern. Und gegen deutlich stärkeres Talent sind sie in der Regel dann schon noch hinten. Also Chelsea zähle ich da jetzt mal bewusst nicht mehr rein. Die haben sie zweimal weggefieselt, sind zwar richtig gut, aber die sind stärker als Chelsea, weil sie einfach viel besser trainiert sind.
Was für eine Aussage eigentlich. Aber gut, da müsste man noch mal tiefer bei Chelsea reingehen. Das machen wir vielleicht an einem anderen Tag. Heute gehen wir noch mal tiefer bei Newcastle rein. Die liegen nämlich einen Platz hinter den Wolves. Und wenn wir das abgleichen mit den Ambitionen und den Transferausgaben, die man so hatte bei Newcastle, dann erkennt man sehr schnell, aha, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich dann eher die negative Geschichte, die Uli uns mitgebracht hat. Woran hakt es denn?
Ja, glaube ich auch. Ist auch im Übrigen ganz interessant, das vielleicht dann noch abschließend an die Wolves, dann können wir den Übergang machen. Da war ja ewig die Fossun Group mit dem, man sagt ja immer, das muss man glaube ich als Journalist schreiben, dem Superagenten, Jorge Mendez, der ja da Ewigkeiten seine Spieler hingetan hat, also dass das die portugiesische Nationalmannschaft B war sozusagen. Der hat nach und nach einen Einfluss verloren und das ist auch gar nicht ungewollt beim Club. Und jetzt setzen sie etwas mehr auf die eigene Jugend. Das war so die Agenda dahinter, dass sie einfach mehr Durchbruch haben wollten aus der Academy plus logischerweise auch schon die Nachhaltigkeitsregeln. Punktabzug bei Nottingham ist jetzt auch wieder ein Thema geworden vor zwei, drei Tagen, sodass das durchaus dafür auch mitverantwortlich ist, dass sie dessen Einfluss und dessen Transfergebaren leicht beschnitten haben. Und das ist der direkte Weg zu Newcastle, weil ich glaube, ganz, ganz viel kann man unterm Strich dann mit der Folge erklären, dass Newcastle richtig Respekt hat vor den Nachhaltigkeitsregeln und deshalb nicht nachverpflichtet hat. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Vorzeitigkeit hat, ich glaube aber, irgendwie kommt eine rein. Was bei Newcastle in dieser Saison der Fall ist, ist, also vielleicht mal vom Grunde her gesprochen, es gab brutale Höhen. Es ging los am ersten Spieltag, dass ich dachte, oh, okay, die sind genauso stark, wie ich sie eingeschätzt hatte mit einem 5-1 gegen Aston Villa. Was sie jetzt im Nachhinein betrachtet, echt eine Aussage ist. Dann hatten sie Spiele wie gegen Paris Saint-Germain, als Fußball Europa auch verstanden, wie gut die sein können. Die hatten 8-0 drin gegen Sheffield und, und, und. Und dann gibt es aber auch unglaubliche Tiefen. Und da fällt mir zum Beispiel ein kurz vor der letzten Länderspielpause in 2.23, 18.30 Spiel gegen Bournemouth, wo sie mit elf, einhalb gesunden Feldspielern hingehen und einfach nicht wettbewerbsfähig sind. Und Bournemouth, die richtig zerrupft, sonst würde da Anthony Rowland gar nicht mehr im Amt sein. Das war damals das Spiel, das ihn gerettet hat. Die haben in dieser Saison, ich weiß nicht warum, das können sie auch nicht erklären, sagen sie zumindest. Es gibt einen Spieler, der eine halbwegs freie Krankenakte hat, Anthony Gordon. Der Rest war schon mal zwei Wochen oder länger verletzt und die kommen auch ganz oft auf einen Schlag, diese Verletzungen, sodass sie nicht reagieren können. Und jetzt dachte man zum Beispiel beim Torwart, bei Nick Pope, okay, jetzt holen die David Rea, weil der zum Beispiel frei ist. Aber noch nicht einmal dieses Gehalt trauen sie sich gegenzurechnen, weil die wissen, wir sind total am Ende. Und jetzt haben die, das haben wir hier auch lang und breit besprochen, Sandro Tonali verpflichtet, also den komplett einzigen sozusagen für viel Geld, von dem sie sich erhofft haben, der wird unser Passspiel auf eine neue Stufe ziehen. Der wird uns im Aufbau so helfen, weil der so anspielbar ist, weil der aus allen Situationen rauskommt. Tja, und dann handelt der sich diese Sperre ein und es ist einfach kein Null zu werden. Und das ist jetzt sozusagen die erste Stufe des Eisbergs. Die zweite ist dann, dass sie normalerweise in Teambarn total kompakt war und physisch war und immer spritzig und den Gegner allein durch diese Physis schon mal ein ganz unangenehmes Spiel gegeben haben. Das wiederum ist aber weg, weil die ja alle entweder teilverletzt oder verletzt waren. Und jetzt hat man so das Gefühl, dieses Kollektive, das Zusammenverteidigen, zusammen jede einzelne Aktion begehen, ist komplett weg. Stattdessen sind sie jetzt nicht mehr beschützt, sondern komplett frei und laufen teilweise in Konter rein. Also es ist nicht selten, dass Newcastle Spiele 3-4 ausgehen. Ich muss mal schauen, wie ich schnell finde auf die Schnelle. 3, 8 Tore in Newcastle Spielen, der Schnitt, die haben letztes Jahr am Stück 1-0 gewonnen. Oder 2-1. Im allerschlimmsten Fall. Aber das war schon furchtbar, wenn sie ein Gegentor kassiert haben, weil es einfach de facto nie passiert ist. Und das ist das große Problem. 0, 0 Kontrolle, 0, 0 Stärke, keine Fitness, kein gar nichts. Und darüber hinaus, und das ist ja das große Problem, das jetzt natürlich auch schon mal nach dem Trainer gefragt wird, Eddie Howe, wie es da aussieht. Ich habe mit einem Kollegen, der ganz gut vernetzt ist, in Newcastle telefoniert, der mir gesagt hat, also zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt gehen alle davon aus, dass Eddie Howe okay sein wird, weil er in der ersten Saison genug angeboten haben sollte. Das Problem ist nur, der Verein ist in Riyadh geführt, aus Riyadh geführt. Und niemand weiß, wie die reagieren da. Also wenn sie denken, okay, der europäische Wettbewerb ist in Gefahr, was machen sie dann? Denken sie, dass sie nicht vor der Entwicklung waren mit der Qualifikation für die Champions League, sondern dass das vielleicht normal war? Was machen sie dann? Die Stellvertreterin hier in England, Amanda Stavely, das ist ja so das Gesicht von Newcastle, die wiederum hat jetzt schon einige Male auch gesagt, nee, Eddie Howe, das passt alles, der ist bei uns total sicher, wir wollen ihn nicht ablösen, nichts. Und der Kollege, von dem ich gesprochen habe, hat mir auch gesagt, die meisten Entscheidungen werden im Moment schon noch in England getroffen, aber wenn die Saudis ihr in West angegriffen sehen, was würde dann passieren? Das heißt, man kann es nicht sagen. Dazu gibt es den Sportdirektor, der das Ganze alles entworfen hat mit klugen Transfers, der sich zu Manchester United verändern möchte. Das heißt, der Club ist irgendwie an so einer Art Scheideweg im Moment. Das heißt, also erstens Verletzungen, weiß man nicht, was das mit einzelnen Spielern macht. Kieran Chippe, der zum Beispiel auch schon mal raus wollte aus der ganzen Geschichte, was sich damals für einen völligen Schwachsinn hielt, weil ich es mir einfach nicht vorstellen konnte. Dann die totale Angst vor den Nachhaltigkeitsregeln und möglicherweise wissen sie auch schon, dass da was droht. Und der Abgang eines Typen, dem man zutrauen würde, als er mit dem ganzen Wahnsinn klar käme. Also eine interessante Phase des Vereins. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, bezwingend negativ, aber interessant.
Ja, definitiv. Und vor allem das Eingreifen der Nachhaltigkeitsregeln. Das ist so interessant, weil man selber hat das so ökologisch noch verknüpft. Aber hier ist es natürlich nur ökonomisch gemeint. Das ist wirklich ein Thema. Also wir haben es in La Liga schon ganz prominent gesehen, Barca und so weiter und andere Clubs, die ihre Spiele nicht registrieren dürfen. Aber halt auch in der Premier League. Und gleichzeitig gibt es ja quasi zwei allerlei Nachhaltigkeitsregeln. Es gibt quasi die der Liga und die der UEFA. Die der Liga sind ein bisschen härter als die der UEFA. Das heißt, wenn du quasi bei denen allein bist, also das hinbekommst, dann schaffst du es auch bei der UEFA. Total interessantes Thema. Gleichzeitig, wenn man auch hört, dass die Bayern immer sagen, wir setzen uns dafür ein, dass es eben solche Regeln UEFA weit gibt und so weiter. Und man gleichzeitig aber erkennt, manche Ligen sind da eigentlich sogar weiter als zum Beispiel die Bundesliga, wo es sowas nicht gibt. Finde ich sehr interessant und hat ja auch auf den Transfermarkt eingegriffen. Ich habe gehört aus dem – jetzt bin ich mal hier Plattigold – aus dem Beraterumfeld, aber es gab durchaus Bundesligisten, die darauf gehofft haben, dass ihnen noch jemand teuer abgekauft wird, der in der Hinterrunde gut performt hat. Aber der Markt war nicht da, weil eben ganz viele Premier League-Vereine genau aus diesem Grund gesagt haben, lieber nicht nochmal nachrüsten. Da müssen wir jetzt mal gucken, ob wir es nicht so hinkriegen.
Ja, ist so. Wenn du dir die Bilanzen des Wintertransferfensters anschaust in England, das war lächerlich. Es war nicht nur für englische Verhältnisse lächerlich, sondern da ist nichts passiert. Ich habe mir zu jedem Team die Stichpunkte gemacht, was ich denke, dass sie tun werden, bevor es losging. Und ich habe bei 20 Clubs, glaube ich, 17-mal durchgestrichen, weil sie nichts getan haben. Und das ist schon erstaunlich. Diese Nachhaltigkeitsregeln sind ja auch eine Wissenschaft für sich. Das hat Richard Masters, der CEO der Premier League, auch noch mal klargemacht. Wir werden nichts erfahren über die Strafen und warum sie verhängt wurden. Es gibt diesen einen Betrag, der drüber steht, so und so viele Minus darf man machen. Wenn du darüber hinaus bist, dann kriegst du eine Strafe. Das ist, was wir wissen im Moment. Wie es berechnet wird, wissen wir nicht. Und das ist zum Beispiel jetzt ganz erstaunlich bei dem Fall Nottingham. Nottingham denkt von sich selbst, sie haben 10 Millionen Pfund weniger Minus erwirtschaftet, als die Premier League ihnen ausweist. Aber, und das ist ja das ganz erstaunliche, also die Fälle sind auf der einen Seite total vergleichbar mit Everton, die ja zunächst mal 10 Punkte Abzug bekommen haben. Das ist dann später reduziert worden auf 6. Und jetzt kriegt Nottingham 4 Punkte Abzug. Die hätten ursprünglich 6 bekommen sollen. Aber, weil sie selbst proaktiv die Unterlagen eingeschickt haben, haben sie das ihnen zugute gehalten und zwei weniger gegeben sozusagen. Und bei Everton war ursprünglich plus zwei, weil angeblich die, so muss ich vorsichtig sein, ob das juristisch korrekt ist, aber weil angeblich die Unterlagen zumindest nicht komplett ausgehändigt wurden. Also war teilweise sogar von Fälschungen die Rede. Deswegen haben sie noch mal plus zwei obendrauf bekommen, in Sachen Minus, wenn es nur allgemein vernünftig ist. Jetzt hat aber grundsätzlich Nottingham einen höheren Betrag an Verstößen ausgewiesen bekommen als Everton, haben aber weniger Punkteabzug. Und jetzt sitzen natürlich die Fans zu Hause und sagen, hä? Und die Premier League sagt, ja, wir können nicht weiter ins Detail gehen, weil das ist zu intim, was dann da rauskäme von den Geschäftsbilanzen der Premier League. Und jetzt sage ich, okay, und was soll ich jetzt machen? Ich kann mich da gar nicht dazu seriös äußern. Ich kann einfach nur sagen, vielleicht geht der Journalismus eh in Richtung Gefühlsjournalismus, dann ist es wieder ganz cool, dann kann man sagen, gefühlt ist das okay oder nicht, aber ich kann dir noch nicht mal eine richtige Außerwelt übertreffen.
Also Uli, grundsätzlich geht es um Sportjournalismus, wer sich für seine Tweets nicht bezahlen lässt, der hat den Schuss nicht gehört. Und dann ist es aber genau dieses Problem, der intransparent und man müsste halt dem Verband vertrauen, oder dem Liga-Verband natürlich, wenn man denen halt so vertrauen könnte. Aber damit sind wir ja quasi schon bei deinem Moment des Spieltanks. Also Nottingham, minus diese vier Punkte, dann wäre man jetzt eben auf einem Abstiegsplatz. Mit den vier Punkten, dann wäre man punktgleich mit Everton, die ja eben die Punkte abgezogen bekommen haben. Ich habe diese Irritation, die du jetzt geschildert hast, die habe ich auch so gelesen bei Fans, die eben mitbekommen haben, Nottingham bekommt Punkte abgezogen, weil dann nämlich gleich der Everton-Vergleichsfall aufgemacht wurde und gesagt wurde, ja, mal gucken, wie viele Punkte das dann wirklich sind und weil aber auch gleich der Everton-Vergleichsfall aufgemacht wurde nach dem Motto, Moment mal, das ergibt ja alles gar keinen Sinn. Du kannst es jetzt ja auch nicht wissen, gleichzeitig habe ich das Gefühl, in dieser Saison werden wahrscheinlich die Standards definiert bei der Premier League, wie man mit solchen Punktabzügen umgeht. Denkst du, da wird sich jetzt in der Berufung doch mal was tun, weil natürlich hat Nottingham Berufung eingelegt.
Ja, denke ich schon. Das hat man zwischen den Zeilen schon so gelesen. Die Premier League hatte ganz fest vor, ganz gleich, was in den Unterlagen Nottinghams stehen würde, einen Punktabzug zu verhängen. Und ehrlicherweise, das muss man ja wiederum zugute halten, der Sheriff Masters, der jetzt durch die Premier League läuft, der hat ja insofern recht, als dass der Rest der Liga weiß, hoppla, lieber nicht. Insofern haben sie recht mit dem, was sie tun. Aber weil eben klar war, sie wollen Abzug verhängen, habe ich das Gefühl, dass sie schon mal eine Karenz eingearbeitet haben von nochmal vielleicht zwei Punkten, vielleicht einer, das weiß ich nicht, aber um… Also diese 10 Punkte Abzug, die sind ja beispiellos in der Geschichte des europäischen Top-Fußballs. Sie haben 10 Punkte in einer Saison. Unglaublich, dass Everton überhaupt noch im Mix war. Wahnsinn. Deswegen wirken die sechs jetzt nicht so hart, die sie jetzt haben, und die vier von Nottingham eigentlich fast schon weich im Vergleich. Das ist schon ein ganz schönes Stück für den Abstiegskandidaten in dieser Liga. Nicht einfach. Ja, ich glaube, da wird sich… Also erstens sage ich, die kriegen Recht. Da gibt es noch eine kleine Reduktion zumindest. Dann ist trotzdem der Punkt der Liga gemacht. Und trotzdem, auf der anderen Seite kommt Nottingham einigermaßen raus. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es noch ein paar Schwächen. Wir haben die Spielklig und Rush lang und breit diskutiert. Es gibt, finde ich noch, also gerade in diesem Nottingham-Fall. Nottingham denkt zum Beispiel, dass ein Transfer hätte reinfließen müssen. Und das ist aus ihrer Sicht, also auch das ist nur Mutmaßung, niemand weiß es. Aber das ist die Mutmaßung. Und so äußert sich zum Teil auch Nottinghams Presseabteilung, dass sie da denken, dass sie zehn Millionen mehr hätten einnehmen müssen. Und denen hat man ihnen aber nicht mehr zugerechnet, weil man gesagt hat, naja, da ist ja der Stichtag. Und dann sagt Nottingham, und das ist im Übrigen Teil der Urteilsbegründung, sie haben ihnen zugute gelegt, dass sie ja versucht haben, Brandon Johnson, also muss Brandon Johnson sein, aber Spieler A ist immer genannt worden, Spieler A wollten sie ja noch verkaufen innerhalb des Junis für dann am Ende, ich glaube, 47 Millionen Pfund und dann wären sie ja komplett in Ordnung gewesen. Und sie haben aber aufgrund eines Beraterwechselns blablabla Spieler A nicht transferieren können. Und jetzt sage ich, ja gut, Moment, also dann sage ich, wenn das Nottingham gewusst hätte, dann hätten sie ja sagen können, Moment, das ist unser wichtigster Spieler der letzten Saison gewesen, dann schleppe ich den gleich bis Ende Mai durch, weil das ist ja urscht. Also dann können wir uns ja selber unsere Zeitfenster bauen. Ab wann muss ich dann anmelden? Wir würden ihn übrigens gerne verkaufen, aber wir finden keinen, weil der muss jetzt die Berateragentur wechseln. Da wird es ein bisschen schwammig und da, glaube ich, gibt es auch noch eine Möglichkeit, also ich habe 0, 0 Ahnung von Jura, aber für meine Verständnis, für meinen Begriff, würde ich denken, da hat Nottingham eine echte Chance. Und da hat aber dann auch Everton eine echte Chance, weil die werden dann auch sagen, also Jungs, wir wollten auch unanah verkaufen, weil wollte halt keiner. Und wie bewerten wir dann die Werte der Spieler? Also wir sind jetzt wieder, wie du vorher gesagt hast, beim Markt. Jetzt kann ja Everton sagen, wir hätten den ja auch gerne im Jahr neu verkauft, aber wegen eurer Regeln kommt ja keiner mehr. Also da sind noch ein paar interessante Themen, die glaube ich nicht so richtig – vielleicht sind sie auch bedacht worden – das Problem ist ja, dass wir nichts erfahren. Also weder wir, noch die Fans, was ja noch viel schlimmer ist, du hattest ja bei Everton jahrelang nur das Gefühl eines Chaos, wir wussten es ja nicht. Es war nur so, okay da haben sie wieder gewechselt, da und da und da und der will dies und der will das und dann gab es ja fast so bürgerkriegsartige Zustände, mal im Dezember des letzten Jahres. Man war schon 22 sogar, wechselt von 22 auf 23 und dann hat man irgendwie gedacht, naja da wird schon irgendwas nicht stimmen und man kann ja ungefähr dann so die Bilanzen insofern, was wir wissen, lesen und sagen, okay Mujiri hat das, das und das und das ausgegeben, hat noch vier Trainer unter Vertrag, okay, wahrscheinlich werden sie nicht wahnsinnig viel Geld einnehmen, aber wir wussten es nicht. Bis jetzt das kam und wir jetzt auch nur die eine Zahl kennen, ein Gesamtminus, das sie gemacht haben und halt wissen, okay, das ist wirklich Chaos, aber mehr wissen wir eigentlich und das finde ich sehr unbefriedigend, muss ich sagen.
Ja, verstehe ich total und gleichzeitig, wer weiß, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Zurückhaltung da Details zu nennen auch daherkommt. Sollte Nottingham jetzt absteigen, dann steht es ihnen ja frei, also außer es ist komplett anders geregelt, aber auch noch vor einem Zivilgericht dagegen zu klagen, dass sie deswegen abgestiegen sind und vermutlich ist man auch bei der Liga deswegen vielleicht in manchen Punkten dann intransparenter, weil man da gar keine Einfallschneisen aufmachen möchte.
Und unter dem Strich aber wahrscheinlich auch etwas nachgiebiger.
Ja, ja, das definitiv, ja.
Wenn du nur zwei Punkte abziehst, dann kann man sagen, naja gut, die hätte da auch unterwegs irgendwo holen können.
Ja, und ob jetzt looten, wenn die dann runtergehen, die haben ja nicht die Lobby, dass die dann sagen können, hey Mensch, wir sind… Ach, es ist ganz fantastisch. Also Nottingham bekommt Punkte abgezogen, wir schauen mal, wie viele. Jetzt fehlt uns dann, das war unser Moment, uns fehlt noch MVP und Anzang Hero. Wer ist denn dein MVP?
Also, als MVP habe ich dir auch schon im Vorgespräch gesagt, hätte man einen nennen können, den man auch als Anzang Hero nennen könnte. Aber wer Fantasy Football spielt, der weiß, dass der nicht unbesungen ist, deswegen nehme ich ihn als MVP. Rodrigo Moniz hat seit Anfang Februar sieben Tore in der Premier League erzielt und das in den letzten sieben Spielen. Der war vorher ein absoluter Verkaufskandidat, zum Teil Stürmer Nummer 3 bei Fulham und ist jetzt mehr oder weniger mangels alternativen auf einmal reingekommen und sieht gut aus. Also, das ist das Witzige. Ich habe Ende Januar mit meinem Bruder gesprochen, der hatte dieses erste Spiel, das er getroffen hat mit Fulham und hat gesagt, und was hast du so zudem, weil ich die zwei, drei, vier Mal in Folge gemacht habe. Also hat von allem ein bisschen, aber ist nicht überzeugend. Und dann hat er mich nach dem Spiel angerufen und gesagt, ja, der hat von allem ein bisschen, das ist ja Wahnsinn, was der alles hat. Also, der ist clever in den Bewegungen, der ist ab dem guten Tor, der ist nicht superschnell, aber hat eine gewisse Dynamik, kann den Ball festmachen, ohne dass man jetzt sagen würde, der geht auch nur in die Nähe des Zielspielers, der hat ein ordentliches Kopfballspiel, aber kein Horst Robesch. Also, der ist ziemlich komplett und vielleicht hat er auch noch ein wenig Potenzial, in jedem Fall funktioniert es bei dem optimal im Moment und so sieht er so fast so Luis Suarez Zero aus, so würde ich es ungefähr ausdrücken wollen. Noch nicht ganz so, also dann noch nicht so geduscht, mit Zucker logischerweise, aber ansonsten geht er so in die Richtung.
Ja, sehr, sehr gut, sehr schöne Wahl Rodrigo Moniz.
Da habe ich jetzt echt lange überlegt, aber wahrscheinlich weil der wirklich wenigen Begriff war und nominiert worden ist zum ersten Mal für die englische Nationalmannschaft, ist das durchaus eine gute Wahl. Cherith Brentwayt habe ich mal genommen, den Verteidiger bei Everton, der von einer durchaus erfolgreichen Lei bei PSW zurückkam, da kann man den schon auf dem Schirm gehabt haben, so ist es jetzt nicht, aber für die allermeisten Engländer kein richtiger Begriff gewesen und ist so, also das ist die Regenkarnation von Primaverde Sacker, muss man so nichts vormachen, und der ist ein guter, harter, großer, starker Innenverteidiger, den jetzt Southgate mitgenommen hat, mal sicherlich auch, weil Gehi nicht available ist gerade im Moment, ansonsten hätte der möglicherweise den Vorzug gehabt, aber da gab es schon ein paar Augenbrauen, die hochgegangen sind, als der nominiert worden ist. Ich finde aber durchaus, dass das einer ist, der eine sehr, sehr konstante Saison spielt und bei Everton auch dafür sorgt, dass sie nicht weiter die Nachhaltigkeitsregeln haben strapazieren müssen, weil der halt schon sehr, sehr gut funktioniert hat und ja de facto, also eigene Jugend ist ein bisschen übertrieben, aber er ist schon eine Zeit lang da.
Sehr, sehr schön. Jared Brandt-Wade, wir hoffen alle, dass er irgendwann mal mit Martin Brandt-Wade zusammen spielt und dass du es dann kommentiert darfst.
Und dann brauchen wir Transferjournalisten, die du, wie ich gelernt habe, sehr schätzt.
Ja, total. Das ist die Zukunft, Uli. Ich sehe mich selbst da. Ich wäre der Maxi-Goal, werde ich in Zukunft sein. Dann brauche ich den Rasenfunk nicht mehr. Uli, ich danke dir sehr herzlich. Es hat große Freude mit dir gemacht, mal wieder hier über die Premier League zu sprechen. Danke, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast. Und danke natürlich auch nochmal an Fabian Pakulat und an Christian Bernhardt und natürlich auch an euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir werden hier auch nicht für einzelne Sendungen bezahlt. Das alles, was will kommen, kommt von euch. Und in dieser Sendung danke ich Tim Ranbach, Tommy, Dominik aus Karlsruhe, Sebastian, Sostinitore, TartanArmy und Ben. Viva Soccer Gourmands, schreibt er noch dazu. Sie alle unterstützen uns auf rasenfunk.de slash supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und an alle, die das schon getan haben, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. Und an alle, die das noch tun werden, voraus auch schon mal herzlichen Dank. Ihr könnt auf rasenfunk.de noch jede Menge andere Sendungen finden von uns, die wir so machen. Ihr könnt uns auf allen Plattformen folgen. Und ihr könnt uns sehr gerne auch weiterempfehlen. Danke, dass ihr hier immer zuhört. Danke für euer Feedback auch im Forum unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Unter diesem Video oder wo auch immer ihr das hier genießt. Habt eine gute Zeit. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt uns gewogen und hört unbedingt auch mal in die anderen Sendungen rein. Es ist wieder sehr viel veröffentlicht worden. Zum VfB Stuttgart zum Beispiel, zur Männer-Bundesliga, zur Frauen-Bundesliga. Alles hier im Rasenfunk. Bis bald.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.